[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de est la rédaction
voici les principaux titres en images de
ce 31 janvier 2017 le compte à rebours
est lancé pour la ryder cup 2018 à saint
quentin en yvelines
une horloge trône maintenant en gare de
montigny le bretonneux le territoire se
prépare à l'accueil du plus grand
événement au monde dédié au golf
yvelines et hauts-de-seine nouveau
budget commun les deux départements
souhaitent se rapprocher vous le savez
et ils viennent de présenter leurs
orientations financières pour la
nouvelle année l'école le troisième à
saint quentin en yvelines qui forme aux
métiers de l'audiovisuel partenaires de
la cérémonie des lumières un exercice
grandeur réelle pour les étudiants que
nous avons suivi en coulisses vous le
savez la prochaine ryder cup
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde de
football mais qui concerne le golf sera
organisée à saint quentin en yvelines en
france donc pour 2018 elle ce sera du 28
au 30 septembre pour communiquer sur cet
événement sur notre territoire un
décompte officiel a été installé
aujourd'hui à la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines le reportage admis qu'elle
ennemis d'euros et d'alice deschamps à
événement spécial un dispositif spécial
un compte à rebours géant est installé
ce mardi 31 janvier à l'entrée de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines sur
l'objectif affiché les jours qui nous
séparent de l'organisation de la ryder
cup au golf national à guyancourt en
septembre 2018 une opération pour
promouvoir le troisième événement
sportif le plus suivi au monde derrière
les jo et la coupe du monde de football
pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas
s'imaginer ses 650 millions de foyers
qui vont regarder cet événement à la
télévision et nous attendons d'eux bien
sûr pour cette grande compétition en
septembre 2018
soixante mille visiteurs par jour dont
une grande partie transite seront ici
par la gare de saint-quentin vente est
chaque jour plus de 70000 personnes
passeront devant ce décompte géant
l'horloge virtuel a déjà attiré l'oeil
des passants
je ne suis pas adepte de golf enfin je
connais pas trop bon baissier mais ça là
pour découvrir cette discipline c'est
une bonne chose
oui oui oui ça permet de découvrir parce
qu'il ya des disciplines sportives qu'on
ne peut être il ya beaucoup de passion
qui peuvent le voir c'est ma manche et
patrux existait avant de passer devant
le panneau en fait donc voilà les gens
vont voir le geste du golfeur la pendule
se pose la question puisse les
animations qui sont en cours son
excellente c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on
fasse il faut qu'on sorte plus de notre
golf et venir voir les gens dans les
prochains mois d'autres opérations de
communication sur cette coupe du monde
du golf sont organisées dans les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
avec ce dispositif les yvelinois
n'auront plus d' excuse pour manquer le
train de la ryder cup 2018
les loups de retour dans les yvelines
c'est en tout cas une rumeur qui court
depuis plusieurs semaines les
associations animalière évoque deux ou
trois animaux qui serait actuellement
localisé entre la vallée de chevreuse et
la forêt de rambouillet il s'agirait de
loups gris italien plutôt présent dans
l'est de la france
les mâles peuvent peser de 25 à 45 kg
les femelles de 18 à 30 kg on écoute
manoel atzmon c'est le président de
l'association alliance avec les nouveaux
le fait qu'ils arrivent sur la région
parisienne est tout à fait normal
puisqu'il ya une pression de la chasse
sur le grand est et du braconnage qui
fait que certains louent décide de
trouver les secteurs où leur chaîne
alimentaire est en nombre et en les
trois principaux sont au nombre
notamment autour de paris on est dans
une situation vous savez c'est une
capitale paris qui est entouré dans ces
dites des départements justement
yvelines et fun fait les marocains par
de nombreuses ferait quoi 13,9 millions
d'euros c'est le budget 2010 est de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines hauts de
seine les conseillers départementaux et
des deux assemblées se sont réunis hier
lundi du côté de vélizy
et ils ont voté presque à l'unanimité ce
deuxième budget comme un budget et qui
marque une réelle accélération dans le
processus vers une fusion entre le 78 le
92 détails sur des images de nicolas
kirillovitch et d'alice deschamps moins
de cinq cent mille euros en 2016 près de
14 millions d'euros en 2017 et un budget
commun x 30 les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
poursuivent leur rapprochement dans le
détail cette année et 12,7 millions
d'euros sont dédiés aux routes
départementales 1 million à
l'archéologie préventive et 100000 euros
au service de l'adoption les
départements versent à l'établissement
public l'argent qui était consacrée au
paravent pour remplir ses missions à
l'euro près et céladon dans un peu plus
de temps dans 18 mois sans doute quand
on aura la comptabilité de
l'établissement public que l'on pourra
voir si effectivement nous avons comme
ça réaliser des économies parmi les 88
élus départementaux 6 des hauts-de-seine
classé à gauche ont voté contre le
budget primitif dans les yvelines sans
opposition politique seul philippe
brillault s'est abstenu je suis
dubitatif sur la pertinence
parce qu'en fait vendredi dernier en
votant le budget des yvelines je n'ai
pas vu l'effet miroir de la diminution
des sommes que j'ai voté aujourd'hui si
nous avons voté aujourd'hui une somme je
dois le trouver en moins à proportion
respective de chaque département
je n'avais pas vu également opposé aux
arguments économiques de la
mutualisation des agents de la cgt
s'étaient rassemblés avant le conseil
d'administration de le pays
il s'inquiète notamment pour leurs
conditions de travail
les cérémonies de voeux du mois de
janvier sont être terminé dernier maire
de saint quentin en yvelines à
s'adresser à ses administrés jean michel
fourgous à elancourt présents pour
l'occasion vous le verrez dans un
instant valérie pécresse la présidente
de la région ile de france et gérard
larcher le président du sénat des
personnalités qui sont venus également
soutenir le candidat fourgous le maire
se présentent en effet est sous
l'étiquette les républicains dont la 11e
circonscription
concernant sa commune la priorité pour
2017 sera donnée à la sécurité
avec toujours le projet d'un nouveau
commissariat mais il sera aussi question
d'emploi écouter
on a un peu moins 10% de chômage mais il
faut encore améliorer ça c'est pas
normal on doit faire beaucoup mieux que
ça donc faut intensifier les forums sur
l'emploi intensifier les les incubateurs
que vous avez vu les aides pour nos
entrepreneurs pour ceux qui créent la
richesse l'emploi qui font rentrer des
nouvelles recettes fiscales et sociales
dans les caisses qui va nous permettre
de payer nos retraites 300 milliards
quand même bien sûr les factures de
l'hôpital bien sûr de tout cela il faut
bien assurer avant tout la durabilité du
financement donc nous nous y sommes des
gens sérieux ni les jambes droites on
est des gens de l'entreprise
on rigole pas avec la stabilité d'un
financement
on prend à présent la direction de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la structure
qui a débuté jeudi dernier son cycle de
conférences sur la thématique du genre
le rendez vous est destiné aux étudiants
aux personnels administratifs et aux
enseignants chercheurs
le premier rendez vous était centrée sur
marie curie et les femmes de laboratoire
le reportage est signée michael et demi
d'euros et patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est une première à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines un
cycle de conférences sur la thématique
du genre est organisée à partir de ce
mois de janvier jusqu'au mois de mars
dans la structure au programme quatre
rendez-vous pour débattre sur l'égalité
entre les sexes et les préjugés dans la
société française on peut modifier les
représentations et on peut modifier les
stéréotypes de sexe bien sûr dans un
domaine comme la physique ou l uv est ce
qu on a 35 pour cent des étudiantes
contre 65 % d'étudiants
effectivement on peut se poser la
question de l'impact des stéréotypes de
genre dont le choix d orientation des
étudiantes pour ouvrir ce cycle une
conférence sur les femmes du laboratoire
de marie curie était programmé
l'histoire de la chercheuse prix nobel
de physique en 1903 et prix nobel de
chimie en 1911 attiré une centaine de
personnes s'est en fait marie curie née
que né le que le prétexte justement pour
présenter le fait qu'elle n'était pas
seule femme scientifique de son époque
et éventuellement
le rôle qu'elle a joué mais surtout le
rôle que l'histoire lui a fait jouer
dans dans cette définition d'une femme
scientifique
le cycle de conférence se terminera le
31 mars il abordera entre autres les
questions de l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin ou encore la thématique de la
place des femmes dans le milieu
artistique
vous avez pu le suivre sur notre antenne
hier soir se déroulait la 22ème
cérémonie des lumières au théâtre de la
madeleine à paris la presse étrangère à
récompenser le cinéma français une
trentaine de films étaient en
compétition et ce sont des étudiants de
saint quentin en yvelines les étudiants
de l'école troisième l'institut
international de l'image et du son qui
est basée sur l encours et qui
s'occupait de la captation de l
événement nous les avons suivis en
coulisses moins de deux heures avant
l'arrivée des premiers invités et une
répétition pour régler les derniers
détails cadres sont ou réalisations les
différentes sections de l'institut
international de l'image et du son sont
mobilisé une soixantaine d'étudiants
assure la préparation et la captation de
la 22ème cérémonie des lumières
je crois que c'est la sixième année que
les étudiants participent activement à
cette l'organisation de cette cérémonie
c'est surtout pour nous l'occasion de
faire un exercice très pratique
puisqu'on est devant la profession
donc c'est aussi pour ça que les ans et
des enseignants viennent encadrer le
travail des étudiants puisque
aujourd'hui c'est un soir important à la
fois pour le monde du cinéma mais aussi
pour notre école après une mise en place
rigoureuse fin des principaux réglages
les étudiants peuvent souffler un peu on
a sonorisé toute la salle derrière des
pupitres au micro des présentateurs
aussi donc ça va réagir je vais en fait
encadrer un peu les présentateurs donc
les accompagner dans leur loge faire en
sorte que voilà il soit confortablement
qu'ils puissent travailler en silence à
19h les lauréats et remettant commencent
à arriver dans la salle tout est prêt
pour les accueillir
là il est 19h20 ça va mieux
non c'est lourd à gérer parce que pas
loin d'une centaine d'étudiants à gérer
on est une équipe une dizaine de
permanents pour encadrer tous ses
étudiants le stress de respecter des
horaires de respecter des délais de
respecter des personnes aussi de se
respecter entre eux 21h la soirée est
lancée en régie comme en salle la
cérémonie se déroule sans problème
majeur
grand gagnant de cette édition elle de
paul verhoeven avec isabelle huppert
il repart avec les prix meilleur film
meilleur réalisateur et meilleure
actrice
23h clap de fin des prix lumières
l'an prochain ce sera au tour des
nouvelles promotions de relever le défi
[Musique]
c'est un nouveau festival qui va voir le
jour dans le département des yvelines il
s'appelle féminin pluriel et il est
meuse est menée par le réseau créative
une association de directeurs de théâtre
et de centre culturel la première
édition se veut un coup de projecteur
sur la création féminine dans la culture
un milieu qui ne compte que 27 % de
metteuse en scène plus de précision avec
ce reportage
un festival pour promouvoir l'égalité
hommes femmes c'est le projet mené par
l'association créative c'est dans ce
lieu symbolique la maison elsa triolet
aragon que s'est tenue une conférence de
presse pour présenter ce nouvel
événement culturel est ce qui a été très
important c'est que déjà créatif depuis
donc est un réseau de 16 théâtres de
villes dans les yvelines et puis un dans
le val d'oise qui nous rejoint pour
l'événement avait déjà soutenu des
projets mais deux à trois projets par en
donnant une petite part de coproduction
à des femmes est évidemment au bout de
trois ans est venue naturel le dire mais
comment allons nous faire savoir et
rendre plus lisibles ce besoin de deux
d'aider les femmes dans la production
pour qu'il y ait une meilleure parité 28
projets portés par des femmes seront
présentés afin de mettre en avant la
création féminine dans le spectacle
vivant un milieu où les femmes sont sous
représentées selon une étude menée par
la société des auteurs et compositeurs
dramatiques
le secteur ne compte qu'un pourcent de
compositrice et 12% de directrice de
théâtres nationaux pour voir des mecs
des metteurs en scène sommes des chefs
d'orchestre comme des chorégraphes au
mode séries où sont passés les gonzesses
dans tout ça où est ce qu'on les a
perdus donc et un moment il faut il faut
aller les chercher il faut leur dire que
leur place elle est là et il faut y
aller quoi si c'est ce dont elles ont
envie il faut pas s'excuser d'être là je
pense profondément que c'est par la
culture qu'on avait va à à changer les
mentalités et que c'est par la culture
qu'on a peut-être plus de levier pour
que cette égalité homme-femme cette
parité
seize d'étrave veut jeu et qu'on n'est
même plus à se battre pour ça labellisé
sexisme pas notre genre par le ministère
des familles et du droit des femmes
l'initiative est à soutenir sur une
plateforme de crowdfunding le festival
se tiendra du 20 février au 1er avril
mais se veut éphémère il espère ne plus
avoir à mener ce combat dans quelques
années
c'est la fin du journal demain mercredi
rendez vous aux horaires habituels avec
nicolas kirillovitch pour une nouvelle
édition les programmes se poursuivre sur
notre antenne replay sur notre site
internet et sur notre application mobile
très belle soirée
[Musique]